My name is Dozie Anyaegbunam,
co-founder of gidimo.
Gidimo is a personal
advancement tool
that uses mastery of
concepts and topics
to drive a student
or professional
to learn a particular course
or pass a particular exam.
By localization,
we're basically trying
to say that when you're trying
to solve a user's issue, a user
problem, and you're trying to
deliver a product that delivers
value and solves
a user's problem,
it's important to consider who
the user is, where the user is
coming from, the culture, and
the environment in which a user
has been in throughout
his or her life.
The way I would say we're
doing it is, first of all,
it's very important
to, after scoping out,
or after writing out what
your your product idea is,
it's important to
pilot and get feedback.
So that way, that
single action in itself
helped solve a lot of the
problems we stumbled into while
building our product.
A big example
could be broadband.
So in Nigeria right
now, broadband is still
a big issue for people.
So if you build an
app, if you take
an idea that relies heavily
on heavy data usage,
then that idea
isn't going to work.
Because then that
means you're going
to kick out the majority
of the consumers who
struggle with data right
here at the moment.
What we found that
some of the users
will register on multiple
phones with the same account,
just because they
wanted to win the prize.
So at that end, we
now had to start
adjusting to capture
this this kind of people
who play on multiple accounts.
And at the same time, weed
them out of the system
so that we ensure that everybody
who pays fairly gets to win.
Down here, a lot of Africans
like having big phones
because they feel that
the phone-- then they can
see everything on their phone.
Now, that affects what
you're going to do with them.
It affects the kind of product
you're going to give them.
It affects the kind
of image you're
going to use when you're
developing the app you're
developing for them.
Localization helps
keep us in check.
It ensures that at every
single point in time,
we are creating a product
that the consumers understand,
and a product that solves a
problem we think they have,
or the problem they
know they have.
[MUSIC PLAYING]